TO YOU BY CHEVROLET.
THE RANGERS THE FOURTH BEST ROAD
TEAM IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE.
>> STOLARZ LET THIS GO BEHIND AD
WHAT CHANCNC
CHANGING DIRECTIONS IN THE RIGHT
IT BACK BLINDLY CENTERING AND P.
HERE IS THAT REDIRECT.
HE ERASES EVERYTHINGRM AND BODY.
IT SAT THERE FOR A SPLIT SECONDN
MOVE QUITE A
BUT IN THIS BACK BEHIND THE NET
AND BOTH TEAMS CHANGE. WAS
WELCOMED IN.
HE WAS TAPPED TO PLAY ON
THURSDAY AGAINST THE RED WINGS
AT THE HONDAONE POINT IN TIME.
HALF OF THE NHL IN GENERATING
SHOTS ON GOAL. ICING. LONG SHIFA
FEW MOMENTS AGO.
THIS ONE DISRUPTED AND PARTIALLY
BLOCKED BY ZEGRAS.
>> WE AURNED
AWAY BY STOLARZ.
>> A CHANCE FOR LUNDESTROM AND
IT'S IN THE GLOBAL STOLARZ.
BACK TO THE LINE AND LINDGREN
HOLDS IT IN.
WATCH NUMBER 26 AND BACK PERIOD.
FORTY